ونبدا من الحدث الاهم في امريكا في سابقه
تاريخيه وجهت هيئه المحلفين في نيويورك
الاتهامات للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في
قضيه دفع اموال
لاسكات ممثله اباحيه قبل انتخابات الرئاسه
الفين 2016 ليصبح ترامب لذلك اول رئيس
امريكي توجه له اتهامات جنائيه في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده ترامب كان توقع توجيه
التهم له في منشورا على منصته تروس سوشل
حيث هاجم فيه مدعي عامه الديمقراطي
بسبب ما وصفه بتسييس لملفه وفي التفاصيل
وبعد ان صوتت الهيئه هيئه المحلفين في
نيويورك على توجيه الاتهام للترمب اصدر
المتحدث باسم المدعي العام في منهات الفن
بريك بيانا قال فيه ان المكتب اتصل بمحامي
ترامب لتنسيق تسليمه تمهيدا لمحاكمته
وبالرغم من ان التهم ليست معروفه تحديدا
بعد الا انه من المتوقع
ان يمثل ترامب امام المحكمه يوم الثلاثاء
من اجل مثوله لتلاوه الاتهام وبحسب مصادر
شبكه سي ان ان فانه من المتوقع ان يتراس
القاضي اخوان مارشن جلسه المحاكمه
من جانبه رفض الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الادلاب باي تعليق على هذا الاتهام الذي
وجهه للدعاء العام في منهات الى ترامب
ومنافسي المحتمل ايضا في انتخابات عشرين
اربعه وعشرين كان الصحفيون في البيت
الابيض قد وجهوا عده اسئله بهذا الشان الى
بايدن قبل ان يغادر الى ميسيسيبي رافضا
التعليق على الموضوع و حامي ترامب كما
نشاهد يقول اتفقنا مع المدعي العام على
الا يتم تقييد ترامب اثناء توجيه
الاتهامات